[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
has to put her mom in a long-term care
facility and she is struggling we also
talked to another mom whose 16-year-old
daughter attempted suicide and the whole
family is struggling and we talk about
some listener feedback to one of my last
calls stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show we're so
glad you're with us we're talking about
relationships and mental health and
school and education in hospitals and
all of it
we have a
fascinating show today ahead of you
can't wait to get into this
kelly listen
uh before we get going i got a
parenting call from
john in nashville and he needs some help
so
i don't
even know what to say about this
so the other morning i
walked in after
being johnny exercise and my daughter
was in there at early in the morning
and by the way anyone who starts a
sentence like i just did is an idiot
it's such a ridiculous flex and i don't
mean to do it like that i just try to be
honest so it was sweaty and gross
but i walked in and i kissed my daughter
on top of the head
and said good morning i love you
do what she replied
ugh
i wish you would cease to exist
i was like number one no more harry
potter for you that's a lot
and
my wife she jumped in and she's like
that was rude and ugly i didn't know
what to say to that none of that was in
my grad school classes like what did
when your five-year-old says i wish you
were dead i don't know what to say and
then i asked her why did you say that
and again you're not supposed to ever
ask the word why
and she said
because you always just kissed me and
told me that you love me and i'm sick of
it
[Laughter]
kelly from john in nashville what what
do i do with that
usually that doesn't happen for like
another eight
ten years oh we were way out we were way
up there yeah you've got a long road she
also was smoking at the time and she was
out of bourbon in one hand number three
that's right
that's right um usually because i'm a
bit of a sarcastic person
um
my response is well tough have i have i
told you the uh
the sarcasm thing
about uh i was i was at a counseling
conference i think this was like at
harvard i mean somewhere fancy
and they were talking to us as though we
knew these things and as a new parent i
was just nodding along but i had no idea
what they were talking about
and they said oh you know that kids
can't process sarcasm until the age of
seven
to which i was like i need you to say
that again say what because about 88
not 80 that was a lie 98 of the words
spoken in my home were just sarcasm and
they said kids will nod and smile and
agree with you
but until they're seven or eight or nine
they just download that as fact and i
just thought oh no oh no so we've tried
to change that with my my son lost calls
but i've tried to change that with my
daughter
but she's the first time one of your
kids comes back with a sarcastic remark
though
yeah oh the sun's getting good it's
great i know it makes my heart feel a
little bit a little bit bigger i'm like
hey you can never ever say that but that
was awesome yeah yeah exactly that's
good i love it i love it so um
she hugged me today so it feels like a
win
you can't take anything kids say to
heart i know and i tell everybody that
for a living when your kid says i wish
you would cease to exist it just feels
like a lot so i have patronus tur i
don't know what they do in harry potter
is what you do you patronus
that's right
he's right ben yeah no it's not yeah how
do you like that
kelly hmm
all right hey so i want to start today
with this email that kelly forded me so
thanks for um
dayruner.com.net kelly
but this is actually serious and i
remembered this and um
yes i just want to put this out there
so here's the email um i listened to
your show this morning on um monday
august 30th which means we probably
filmed this sometime in july
uh maybe early early august i had tears
in my eyes for the woman who had to
listen to her child tell her
how father was basically verbally
abusing him on his own time
and i was dismayed to hear you me tell
her to get a lawyer and fight him in
court
your other advice such as telling him
that he isn't stupid and getting him a
therapist and all that stuff was spot on
however i was sad to hear that people
actually believe the court system is
going to do anything about a father
yelling at his child and then she goes
on to tell me about some context in her
situation her child is autistic adhd
epileptic has various other struggles
and she spent five years trying to
convince him that
her ex that kid shouldn't stay up all
night um they should
have to take their seizure medications
then um dad just doesn't get to decide
you know what i think medications are
bull crap i'm not giving them to them
um they shouldn't be giving them at two
or three in the morning whenever they
forget and have to wake up a kid and
anyway
she goes on to say we've had a long
drawn-out fight that when he doesn't
take his meds and all those kind of
things um
it's a mess
she's called cps called aps and even
worked with a lawyer and she goes on to
say nobody cares besides me the court
system will not remove kids even from a
physically abusive situation sometimes
cps will child protective services
whatever they are in your state but
that's a crapshoot
anyway all this to say my experience is
that family court is a sad horrible
place that often the best interests of
the children is not actually what
happens
i could give you many of my friends
whose children have been totally left
aside by the court system and given back
to abusive parents
all that i'm saying is please be gentle
please please be gentle on us moms who
have to go through this nightmare of an
abusive ex-husband or even dads with an
abusive ex-wife
any amount of hope that this can
actually change can be detrimental
so
one thank you so much for writing in
it means the world that you took time to
write about your experience
and this is one of the rare shows
that i left and i was sick to my stomach
all the way home
because she's right
now
i've worked closely with family lawyers
they're awesome they try so hard i've
worked really closely with family court
appointed
they are incredible the work they do is
incredible who they are is incredible
what they're what they're doing in the
world is incredible
and it's a mess
and occasionally on the show i get calls
that um there's not a great answer to
it's a matter of what sucks less or it's
a matter of yeah this is the situation
you're in you've got a husband who or an
ex-husband
who's not a good person
they they're terrible they suck and
they're taking all of their world's crap
out on a nine-year-old an 11 year old
and it's heartbreaking
and in those kind of moments on this
show i can say i mean
you can go get a lawyer and try to fight
this and you might find the right judge
the right lawyer um your ex-husband may
not show up to court he may say
something stupid he may say you know
what i don't even want custody anymore
and that's what we're aiming for in
those situations
but also there's a reality to this and
i've heard this over and over too
that um
sometimes there's not a lot you can do
and for those folks who are dealing with
a crappy axe
i'm sorry it's hard hurts
you're playing a long game with your kid
and you're not only combating negative
stuff
you're not uh you're not living while
your child's being traumatized by
somebody who forgets to give them their
medications for seizures and oh yeah
wakes up four beers in wakes them up at
three 3am he's like hey you go take your
meds doesn't get him to school on time
doesn't make sure they're bathing
doesn't calls him stupid says you're an
idiot says in this house we make free
throws that kind of nonsense i'm so
sorry
um you're playing a long game with your
kid and you're not gonna be able to
speak that out of them you're gonna have
to love that out of them you're gonna
have to show them over time and over
time over time and you're gonna wanna
say bad things about their dad bad
things about their mom i don't i'm gonna
continue to double down and say don't do
that
but it's hard
and if you are an ex
and that's you
stop
stop
stop stop
kids need
routine they need their medication
whether you read some internet article
or not
they need you to show up to
school events they need you to get over
the like your petty differences between
your ex and you all show up together be
grown-ups for your kids
don't beat up your kids don't scream at
your kids don't call your kids stupid
and if you find yourself doing that stop
and if you can't stop go get some help
and quit because you're you're creating
generational drama to deal with it too
stop you especially know how much this
hurts
and i don't like my tax dollars having
to go to support these attorneys and
these these judges
because you can't parent
because you're a jerk because you take
out credit i forgot dude i forgot my
video games the game was a shut up and
fix it
stop these are kids
kids
man
[Music]
thank you so much um i didn't i didn't
let this this author know i was gonna
read this email thank you for writing in
and hey anytime i say something on the
show that you're like man i don't really
think that's right or i haven't had that
experience or i appreciate that but
man my experience was different please
write in
and if you are found yourself in a
situation where you aren't uh a spouse
an ex-spouse and you're not treating
your kids right today's the day that you
change today's the day change we'll be
right back on the dr john luna show
[Music]
you always hear me talking about how
good deep sleep impacts your anxiety
your depression your attitude your
mental health your physical health your
work performance sleep is critical to
every single thing in your life and if
you want to change the way you sleep you
first start with a world class mattress
one that you can actually afford and you
know i only recommend things that me and
my family use in our home and that's why
i partnered with dream cloud mattress
dream cloud gives you premium
world-class materials in a mattress at
half the price they utilize innovative
sleep signs to build mattresses that
keep you cool that support you in any
position and it adapts to your body i
made sure they have price points for
every budget dream cloud is for you they
are currently running their biggest
offer ever a total of 650 bucks in
betting and cash savings exclusive for
dr john dolone's show listeners they
also have a 365-day home trial sleep on
it for a year and if you don't like it
send it back visit
dreamcloudsleep.com get 650 in savings
and goodies and start sleeping today
all right we're back let's go to alexis
in
philadelphia where i was born and raised
not really that was just a will smith
reference how are you alexis
hey dr john how are you i'm doing well
thanks for taking my call you bet thanks
for calling what's up how can i help
okay so i have a unique one for you it's
a little long-winded so just bear with
me um my mother recently suffered her
second stroke in three years this past
year
thank you
in addition to other major accidents
such as falls a hip replacement and
things of that nature
the second stroke has seemed to impair
her cognitive function in terms of
decision making short-term memory and
insight across
according to her medical discharge
but it's also evident that over the
course of these last few months since
her stroke that my mom seems to be using
this i want to say an air quote
impairment as a tool to manipulate
multiple situations in her life
and one of the situations that she's
manipulating right now is her long-term
care plan such as the in-home nursing or
a retirement community
she continually tells me that she is not
quote ready for assisted living at 66
years old
and um that the medical professionals
don't know what they are talking about
of course um
right
so out of everyone in this situation
which involves just her herself right
now because she her um husband she has a
late husband um her sister uh which is
who is 55 and her brother who is 57
she's the oldest of three and then
myself so out of everyone involved i
seem to be the one impacted most
negatively from this manipulation how
come why are you why are you the most
negatively impacted
mostly because i'm her primary caretaker
okay um you have medical power of
attorney
i do a medical and and uh adorable okay
are you on the advanced directive do you
get to make those
well so that's that's been an issue this
past summer is they are trying to
contest that saying that she signed the
power of attorney um incompetent
so um as of right now it's on hold yes i
am capable of writing checks to her
in-home nurse but that has been a poor
issue who's contesting this her siblings
her her siblings correct gosh
so they're saying that she was
cognitively impaired when she signed her
directives
and they're taking you to court over
that
correct and why are they does she have a
big estate why are they
they don't want her in home like what
what are they trying to fight you for
well
so so that's what we're trying to
understand is that we believe we have a
reason to believe through text messages
and phone call conversations
that they are in denial about her state
um they don't they also agree with her
that she's not you know quote unquote
she keeps using the word ready for
assisted living um and so
we
don't have the
answer for that right now but that is
the million dollar question um but my
question my question for you is that um
you know she does use this manipulation
and they are feeding
her what she wants to hear why do you
know what do you think why do you so
if she's neurologically impaired if
she's got early stage dementia if she's
got alzheimer's if she continues to have
um strokes
she's got legitimate physiological
neurological damage
and so it may be what makes you think
she is manipulating you versus she's
really struggling with some sort of um
for lack of better terms this isn't
really medically accurate but she's got
some sort of traumatic brain injury
um
and she's being handed a script by
people that she's known for 50 years and
she's following that script what makes
you think that she is
you're saying two different things one
she is using this as a tool for
manipulation and she also cannot make
decisions on her own cognitively and she
needs to be put in a home so which one
of those is it because it feels like
you're splitting the difference there
yeah so so the things that have happened
that makes us i ask my husband i believe
that she may be even this manipulation
is um so all summer long i took her
around and toured assisted living
facilities so that
we could be prepared for this um
she
then um
tells friends and family that my
daughter is putting me in a home without
giving proper context to the entire
situation so so listen let's let's let's
let that go
is this 65 60 how 65
66 66 year old woman
who is feeling her mind and her body
slowly
leave her
and
from the folks that i've had an
opportunity to talk to who are in this
early stage it's one of the most
horrifying terrifying feelings just to
feel your body leaving you
and so yes they're gonna couch stories
because any admission like i need help
is gonna sound like a weakness a
brokenness and so it's much easier to
pawn it off on somebody does that hurt
being her daughter oh my gosh yes
but i would cycle out of the blame and
the reality is
you are
you are putting her in a home and she is
saying i don't want this and you're
saying no we're going to do this so her
her action her her words are technically
true
and i would have you just let go of the
you need to tell the full story in the
context like you're watching you're in a
very hard season where you're watching
the woman who raised you
slowly lose herself does that make sense
absolutely and and i guess to add to
that too um it's not just that she's
saying my daughter's forcing me into a
home i i've really have been keen to her
wishes and her will and we have open
conversations about her well which is
why i think sometimes she's in tune and
knows what's going on and then sometimes
she uses it to say i forget i don't
remember um so the language that she
uses with her friends and the family
members like her siblings or my my
daughter forcing me into assisted living
isn't accurate to what we discussed um
and so i followed her wishes i didn't we
wouldn't even though we toured assisted
livings and we didn't follow through
with that i then asked if she was okay
with in-home
care a nurse to come she said sure so i
hired an in-home nurse
and then she went behind my back to a
lawyer and told her the lawyer that i
wasn't putting her in assisted living
according to her discharge papers but
instead i was hiring a nurse at home
um
but listen listen
you're talking to someone with some
major cognitive challenges
she's not she's not fully she's not
she's not neurotypical anymore she's
struggling
and certain days she's going to remember
certain things in different ways
right and so what you're doing is you're
trying to hold a character issue over a
physiological challenge
and i'll tell you that's causing you a
ton of unnecessary heartache when you
love somebody and you're in charge of
the care of somebody
who is an early stage dementia or who's
a multiple stroke sufferer it's
heartbreaking it's brutal it's awful and
you're experiencing this it affects your
marriage it affects your kids it affects
everybody and then when you're in this
super unfortunate situation where her
brothers and sisters decide to go to war
two for who knows what reasons
or let's let's give them the benefit of
the doubt they're getting these
heartbreaking texts from their sister
saying my daughter's forcing me into
this or what
your situation unfortunately is all to
not i mean all too common
and that doesn't mean it's not right
but what you're gonna have to do is love
your mom and through these moments
because she's just not
thinking linearly like you and i do does
that make sense
it does yeah it's hard you're trying to
fix a moral or character issue
and that's not a moral character issue
to fix
and i think your heartbreak in this
situation and your grief over watching
your mom slowly unspool
is causing you to double down on
something very similar to how she's
trying to double down on something
she she's losing something so she's
gonna blame you and then y'all gonna
come to this great agreement the next
day she's gonna wake up her body's gonna
be feeling different she's gonna have
different thoughts different memory
patterns and then she's gonna call
somebody else that she knows and trust
and says my daughter's doing this to me
because she's scared and she's terrified
and you're in a very similar situation
where y'all agree on something she calls
and
gets a lawyer and then you get mad at
her and sh it's kind of like
you have young kids
i'm actually currently six months
pregnant and have an 18 month old there
you go okay so um i don't want to
compare this wouldn't be fair people are
going to write mean things about me on
the internet but um the closest the
closest thing i can tell you is
your eight month 18 month old may do
some things that you would think why did
you just barf on me
you know what i mean
that's gross and you wish they wouldn't
do that but it's not a moral or
character issue and so you handle it
differently does that make sense
it does it does and so are you holding
medical papers saying that she is
um
that she is struggling cognitively
has she been diagnosed with dementia
with alzheimer's not not quite we're in
that evaluation process right now the
papers that i have say that she needs
assist these are from the discharge
after the stroke that she needs
assistance with finances and she needs
assistance with she's got a lot of
drives she needs assistance with um
anytime she needs transportation so
what's made you think that she needs
assisted medical care as well
um
i've known my mom for a really long time
i've seen the decline happen i've seen
her wobbling around so the first stroke
left her physically impaired the second
one has left her
uh cognitively impaired so i want i want
you to get with a medical doctor and say
and also and also medical professionals
have said if i said off-record if this
is your mother what would she do because
she does live alone she is by herself
they said probably some type of facility
would be better than in-home nursing but
again she was resistant to that so
that's why we landed with the in-home
nursing care for now and so we can find
the long-term solution and what i would
tell you is you are passed
off the record
you need on the record because your
mom's trying to fight you illegally your
aunts and uncles are trying to fight you
legally you can't do off the record
anymore
and so you need to get these things in
writing and that's the medical coverage
you need
because you've got the medical power of
attorney you just need the medical
professionals to give you their
professional opinion which is she needs
elevated care that you can't provide
that can't be provided in home
and
it will be one of the if not the most
heartbreaking seasons of your life
because your mom will scream
she may cry
she may send you messages saying why do
you hate me why are you taking me out of
my home
why i don't you'll have aunts and uncles
will turn on you
and that's when you have to have a group
of people in your life that you can turn
to that aren't them
that will hold your arms up because this
one's gonna be hard
so this is my question for you am i
morally obligated to work to maintain a
relationship with her and her siblings
while
they all align with each other and
are trying to be combative with me her
yes
her yes but that relationship's gonna
look different it is not gonna be the
friendship that y'all have had
it's not gonna be the
um
hey mom what do you think about this
it's gonna be you in some ways becoming
the parent here
and in the same way that your 18 month
old doesn't get a vote on things it's
gonna flip that way that's why your mom
when she was um
um
when she was in her right mind if you
will
which is an ugly way to say that when
she was in her right mind she chose you
so that when these things happen i've
got somebody i trust come what may
and what's coming is her brothers and
sisters are going to war with you she's
going to war with you not intentionally
but she is
and so yeah you got to maintain a
relationship with her and sometimes
that's going to be you show up to see
her once a week and she's going to say i
don't want to see your face
and it's going to break your heart and
you're going to weep and you're going to
have to have somebody you can go to and
talk to
and
but also
you're still going to write her a letter
every week tell her how great she is and
you can do the best you can to let your
grandkids be there and her brother and
sister are just getting notes from her
saying help me my daughter's crazy
and so as as hard as they're gonna fight
you know that they're trying to fight
you on behalf of your mom too
does that make sense
yeah it does it's brutal
that's right that's right and if if you
told me there was a multi-million dollar
estate and they were getting ready to go
to war over that that sucks right yeah
i'm going to choose to say that to
suggest that they are just getting these
raw messages from somebody that they
love
who's been basically a mother figure to
them right she's old enough she's a
decade older than them so she probably
had a maternal uh was played a paternal
role in her life and they're saying oh
my gosh crazy crazy pregnant daughter
has just gone nuts right and that's you
right right um she just wants mom's
money or she just doesn't want to deal
with this anymore and
in all those evil mean things you do not
have to keep a relationship with them in
fact i wouldn't recommend it
you may want to write them a letter and
say i love them i'm holding doctor's
notes
and it may be if you got real lucky that
a social worker sometimes these
situations assigned social workers and i
would ask for one can sit down and do a
family meeting
that would include you your husband
um her brothers and sisters whoever got
invited
and that the social worker can walk
through or maybe a neurologist can walk
everybody through here's what's
happening in mom's head
here's what's happening in her mind
here's why she might send you these text
messages that are going to sound so
heartfelt and so accurate and they're
completely inaccurate she's just
terrified and scared
over and over so it may be that you can
set that up and that would be remarkable
that's probably a long shot probably not
going to happen
and so anybody i've ever met and this is
in my family too
who have dealt with somebody with
alzheimer's with early stage dementia
with
strokes with those type of mobility
challenges is heartbreaking
but always go back to two things number
one do what the doctors say if they say
you need medical care they need medical
care and number two
they chose you for a reason
they chose you for a reason so that when
decisions got real hard
ugh you would make them you'd make the
right ones
i hate this for you alexis i know this
is hard this is going to be a long
season for you it's been a long season
years
okay
keep showing up keep showing up and keep
showing up
you're awesome alexis we'll be right
back from dr john dalon show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
right we are back let's go to marie in
pennsylvania hey marie what's up
hi dr john how are you we are rocking
and rolling how about you
i'm hanging in there oh goodness
gracious what's going on
um
i'm gonna struggle through this so
please bear with me take your time take
your time
um
my 16 year old daughter um was taken and
admitted to the hospital on sunday due
to a suicide attempt oh marie i'm so
sorry
um
while she's been in the hospital
she was in direct extended contact with
someone that was a coveted positive
staff member
which has now caused her hospital stay
to be much longer than the normal stay
prior to going to a inpatient mental
health program is it because she's been
quarantined
um they haven't necessarily quarantined
her um like i'm able to stay with her
all day um they're they just need a
negative test after 10 days of the
exposure for the facilities to be
willing to take her
okay because because she hasn't
because she was in contact
correct okay um like at the hospital
they have like a one-on-one nurse with
her all the time
um
and that from sunday night to monday
morning a 12-hour shift that nurse
tested positive on monday morning and
she had spent 12 hours with my daughter
has your daughter had any symptoms or
anything is she sick no okay good deal
good deal yeah so can we do can we do
one thing real quick
sure
i want you to
hold your take as deep a breath as you
can and hold it
one
two
three and then let it out slow
it's really hard i know
but marie she's gonna be in there for
ten days and we're going to let that one
go
okay
because you got a lot in your heart and
head right now and you're going to war
over something you can't change so we're
going to let that be she's going to be
there for 10 days she's going to be
surrounded by people who love her and
care for her she's going to get food
she's going to get sleep which are two
critical things right now okay
and so we're gonna let that one go
yes cool absolutely agreed yeah okay
great so she's there for ten days great
yeah what's next um
because of this extended stay it has
allowed me the opportunity to start
researching these facilities
oh no did you look online reviews
all of them marie don't look at the
online reviews
i wish somebody would have told me that
two days ago don't look at online
reviews of psychiatric care don't ever
do that
never never never
oh no i'm so sorry that you did that
okay so has the hospital recommended
places for you yes
and you checked them out and they were
miserable and evil and awful and all
that stuff
every review says don't dare send your
child there of course of course
um
that's a whole show that is a whole show
um and and i understand i mean any any
information you get from people online
you're getting information
people leave reviews when they're angry
i understand it very few people um i
have had the the honor of sitting with a
number of parents who are pulling their
kids out of these situations
often
there is such deep and pro like what
you're experiencing right now such deep
and profound confusion
and grief and loss and mourning that it
is anybody i could possibly pin this on
please
and
psychiatric care facilities are really
hard and they range from
somebody who's 14 who says the words i'm
having dark thoughts and gets caught up
in a school system that dumps them into
a psychiatric care unit and somebody who
is acutely schizophrenic who has
tried to kill themselves multiple times
and they're all in the same room
so it can be terrifying and scary and
all those things and then you get a
parent or a mom who's got their own
challenge and then they go
they've got an opportunity to put it on
the internet right so i would tell you
to not get on those reviews okay
and i know that's so hard because you're
just looking for the best info you got
it's so hard and these are expensive and
people get their kid out and they're so
grateful and they get this bill and you
get angry there right so all to say is
there's not a lot of
um
there's not a lot of incentive for
people to put positive reviews okay
um let's back out for a second
hey tell me about your daughter
she not been doing well does this
surprise you so much i know
i know you do
um
she has struggled with
um anxiety
being anxious and struggled with
depression for years
we have had her in counseling
she's been seeing a great counselor for
10 years um
off and on i mean not every week nuts
we go through
peaks and valleys
where we will see um her counselor
weekly for two or three months and then
we'll go six or eight months and not
really have a need and then something
will come up and we'll go back to weekly
for a little bit what's it what was her
childhood like 10 years with the same
challenges like that lets me know what
she had come from a rough environment
does she have some challenges that she
experienced early on what's home life
um dad and i divorced 10 about 10 years
ago um and that's kind of when all these
things peaked
um
was there is there some challenges
before the divorce
um
i mean between me and her dad of course
that's what i'm saying yeah was it was
there some stuff that okay she was
living in that water is what i'm saying
she was breathing that air that's a
better way to say it correct okay okay
um so now we fast forward and again
that's not for blame that's just i'm
trying to get some context here
and then what happened
did something
did something
acute happen was there a trigger moment
here or did she just get exhausted and
say i'm tired
um i i think it's the past two years
just the chaos the
losing touch with friends um
i think that
she
she's had
a serious boyfriend
and her and the boyfriend
have been
he and age boyfriend girlfriend arguing
lately
and i mean that that has contributed to
some of her anxiety but i i really think
that it's just the past two years of
everyone's world being chaotic and
she's been at home doing cyber school
and
not having good contact with teachers
and
she did not um succeed in her freshman
year of high school she had to repeat
her freshman year because of the online
chaos that she just
i mean she just she didn't she didn't
succeed at that okay
and how did she try to take her life
bills okay
and she took
12 tylenol pms okay and did she leave a
note
no her dad found her okay
um
did he notify her did she send something
out on social media
um he found her in the bathroom okay and
she was um from i was not at the house
of course she was at her dad's house and
um from what i understand he heard her
crying in the bathroom and he opened the
door and she was sitting on the floor
and her extremities were beginning to
turn blue yeah and he called 9-1-1 yeah
yeah okay
um
i'm glad he was there
me too i'm glad thank you
so now she's in a hospital
with around the clock here is that right
have they have they stabilized her she
said i wish um
i can't believe this happened i'm so
glad to see you like what's her state
right now
um she is
she wants me there with her all the time
she doesn't like when i leave
um she has not talked to me about
the what's or the whys or the house i
haven't pushed i haven't really asked i
don't
i don't know if i should
um
she wants to come home
but she she does say that she wants help
she wants to get better she wants
um to learn
how to handle
stress better like she knows she needs
the tools she she says that
and she's willing to go to an inpatient
facility um
but
she can tell that i'm anxious about it
yeah so i think that makes her anxious
about it gotcha so you nailed it just
there
she will absorb you
and that's a lot of pressure on mom
and unfortunately that's what we sign up
for when we become parents
okay and she's going to absorb dad too
are you and dad on speaking terms are
you all co-parents here okay yes um if
possible at all and if y'all are both
married to other people now um it may be
good to bring them in too
but a
what i would call an emergency not
emergency like there's lights flashing
but soon this week next week
i think it would be worth your time
to
go get with a local pastor a local
counselor somebody you could get in a
room with and say here's how we're all
going to walk forward
because what your daughter's going to
need is a united front of people who
love her and are going to hold her
accountable and give her boundaries kids
crave boundaries and the in the thing
that's most
um that usually happens here is everyone
pulls all the boundaries off because
they don't want to say or do the wrong
thing because they think this like i
don't want to be the one who
fill in the blank right and kids are
desperate for them
please give me guard rails right yeah
and but those guard rails can get
oppressive in looney tune also and so
it's just getting everybody in a room no
blame this is all about how are we gonna
love her moving forward and it might be
we're not gonna say i can't believe you
did that i we're gonna have to none of
that right and so getting with a
counselor can say here's five or ten
things we're all gonna agree on
and dad you're gonna write a letter
every week mom you're gonna write one
every day or fill in the blank right
um but getting in a room if y'all can do
that and act like grownups here and your
daughter's desperate for that
then everybody walks out on with a
united front okay um the second is
yes she wants you there every time as
much as possible
and be there as much as you can but if
you got to go to work you got to go to
work
and having somebody there who loves her
whether that's your i don't know if
you're remarried or if you've got other
siblings or an aunt or an uncle or some
a mentor so people can be there that's
great
if they can't they can't what would be
really cool in these moments is to have
a flood of people who love her write her
letters and just say we miss you and we
love you
and here's why that's so important she's
sitting in a hospital feeling like she's
alone and she's just got some nurse
sitting there on her phone
or reading a book or whatever
having something that she can hold
tangibly that when she starts thinking
i'm dumb i'm stupid i don't have this i
don't believe
she's got evidence on top of evidence on
top of evidence that that's not true
and there will be a little bit of
embarrassment and shame i can't believe
i'm so embarrassed but
all of that will be will be
washed away by the onslaught of handheld
letters and so i don't know if you've
got a resource or a connection or
um what her situation is at school
whether teachers or students can write
letters or things like that but those
become worth their weight in gold
for somebody holding into their heart
um and then here's what i would do if
i'm you so i'm just thinking fast
forwarding i'm in your situation i got
two young kids i get the same call and i
race over the hospital and they tell me
that we've did they give her charcoal
and pump her stomach and all that
no they did not they just did blood work
and tested and waited till her tylenol
levels came down oh okay so they just
let that one ride huh
yeah yeah
and that
that's a scary one i had us my son ate a
handful of tylenol and they said we'll
know if his liver stops and that's a
scary scary moment right
yeah
that's one of the scariest moments of my
life i was waiting for that test um he
just they look like candy and my son
popped a bunch and they said we'll know
if his liver stops that's about the best
we can do
and
yeah i remember that
um so
i would get on the phone with the school
counselor
have you talked to her
or him i i have yeah okay
they should have a resource that they
trust
and that's that's where if you can get a
insurance referral and you can go
through there that's where i would go
because they will have looped with
untold numbers of students and their
parents in this very same situation that
nobody knows about
um students disappear and they come back
two weeks later and they're integrated
back into school but that would be the
person i would go to in my local
community if i was in the same same
situation you're in okay
and they should they'll probably give
you two or three and go in and visit
with them and go with your gut okay your
mom you know
and if you start feeling anxious
right yeah
do you struggle with anxiety
oh yeah yeah yeah the apple doesn't fall
far from the trail
so marie you're worth the work too
i'm serious
i know but i'm
i'm i'm not currently in trouble i'm
okay you're not
you're not
my baby is i know but so is marie
so it's marie
hey
am i right
yes yeah i've done this too long marie i
promise you
you're worth the work too
and
when you can
then everybody can breathe
okay
will you call somebody today
absolutely yes
yeah for you i did yesterday i i did i
did yesterday i i made a phone call
yesterday and yeah
i'm you promise
i guess absolutely i did yeah i promise
will you actually go through with it
because you're going to get really
anxious or you're going to go once
you're going to be done
will you please go i will yes sir i will
okay
my heart's with you marie
i appreciate it thank you do you have
people you can sit with
and now i made it weird and you're
trying to get off the phone i'm telling
you right now
okay
yeah
breathe it's it's it sucks it's un
unimaginable if you haven't been sitting
in this situation
how do we get here
right the emotions are really weird
you get really angry
and then you get really sad yeah
and i love her so much but i'm so mad at
her and i'm
it's hard and then you feel guilty and
you're a crappy mom because you're mad
at your daughter and you're not
it's okay to be mad it's okay to be
raged out it's okay to be pissed off
it's okay to regret the last all those
feelings and things are real they're not
truthful but they're real and do you can
you tell the difference there yes yes
so feel them and have somebody you can
say i'm out loud to
write them down wait i'm so pissed off
at you how dare you try to take the most
precious thing in the world from me how
dare you do that
how dare you ex-husband fill in the
blank of all that fun stuff you could
just pile on that you know you could
dump in that yeah right all of it yeah
it's real it's not all true but it's
real
yeah
and you well i can tell you right now
marie you don't believe you're worth
fixing right now and fixing's a bad
thing you don't feel like you're worth
healing right now because your baby's in
the hospital
and what i'm telling you is you gotta
eat and you gotta sleep and you gotta
have oxygen too
and you've heard that being said over
and over and over again that you gotta
put your oxygen mask on first and it is
never more true than right now
okay i hear you
you promise i'm only telling this guy i
love you i i'm telling you right now
i'm trying i know you are this isn't it
it's not a try it's not like work hard
or do harder i'm not trying to be jocko
here right i'm i'm trying to tell you
i came home last night and ate a bag of
beef jerky and drank a bottle of wine in
the bubble bath so i think that was good
for me
hey you get one of those and you already
burned it but you get one right
yeah and you probably woke up this
morning
with the greatest guess of all time is
that fair
it was fun
[Laughter]
i've got still got um i still don't
smell well after covet and
i i'm even i'm glad i'm not in the
pennsylvania area but listen you got you
get you get one or two of those but i
want to make sure you got someone you
can call and say i'm really pissed off
right now and they're not gonna say well
you shouldn't be they're gonna say i
know i hate that for you it sucks come
over i do i i i do i have some i have
some good friends and i've been in
contact with them and yes
yes
if the school counselor gives you
nothing go with the resources at the
hospital is going to get you those are
your only choices okay
follow your gut it's going to be
uncomfortable it's going to be hard your
daughter's going to text you and say i
wish i was in here
that some of that stuff is part of the
entry of this deal
right healing from this is going to be
hard lots of shame lots of embarrassment
lots of people that have some major
psychiatric disorders in
patient care with her going
whoa i'm not here right and i've had
some experiences where that was the
greatest thing ever for a young person
like whoa i've got a lot
different situation than some of these
folks here
okay okay um and it will be hard trust
the doctors here and i know that's gonna
be the hardest thing in the world
got it yeah got it marie we are all 100
behind you
let us know how the next few days go
let us know if she gets into a hospital
and we will be rooting for you rooting
for you rooting for you thank you so so
much for that call
every parent out there when your kid
gets sick and something's going
wrong with your kids in the hospital
everything in our body says let's dump
125 of who we are into that situation
and what i want to tell you is you got
to stop and back out because you got to
be okay
ask my baby forget all that i'm telling
you right now i've been to too many
hospitals with too many parents and sat
for too long in these situations
you gotta eat you gotta breathe you
gotta check in with people that you love
you gotta sleep
you gotta be clear-headed and listen to
doctors you gotta write things down you
gotta have friends that you can call and
weep bitterly with and say i hate
everything and i'm pissed off about
everything and i'm angry about
everything
and i miss my baby and i love her all in
the same sentence and they're not gonna
think you're crazy
you gotta have all of that stuff
and you gotta do the hardest thing in
the world which is trust right now
experts you gotta trust the doctors you
gotta trust the people that
it's hard hard hard marie hard marie
but your daughter's gonna be okay
she's gonna come out and go i'm gonna
heal i'm gonna be better and you're
gonna have a group of people rally
around you
thank you so so much for being honest
and vulnerable marie thank you so much
for this call
all right so as we wrap up today's show
kelly came in here at the break
this is one of your favorites of all
time
it is i don't know why it's just it's a
feel-good happy song
and this show needs to end with a
feel-good happy we need that song
so this one is off the 1980 album um
kelly was already 17 when this one came
out right is that fair seriously i'm
sorry that was rude you were not born
yet you weren't even thought of yet well
i was born i'm trying to pick one i know
i was six
see me not making a joke there that was
so hard like four just buzzed through my
head i'm proud of you they didn't come
out of my mouth
you've matured
right in front of our eyes um 1980
record one trick pony the
extraordinary paul simon writes this
song called late in the evening and it
goes like this
first thing i remember i was lying in my
bed and i couldn't have been no more
than one or two and i remember there was
a radio coming from the room next door
and my mother laughed the way some
ladies do and kelly when it's late in
the evening and the music's seeping
through
the next thing i remember i'm walking
down the street i'm feeling all right
i'm with my boys i'm with my troops
and down along the avenue some guys were
shooting pool and i heard the sound of
acapella groups yeah singing late in the
evenings all the girls out on the stoops
yeah late in the evening right here on
the dr john daloni show
you